when words fail emojis prevail yes it's
world emojis day we're busting out some
of our favorites send us yours as well
it's good day las vegas it starts right
now
now live this is
good day las vegas
so many emojis you know every time you
look at the phone it's like oh
there's so many options good morning to
you good morning to you uh uh alex
you're alex i'm john but we already knew
that
yeah i always try to scroll through like
which emoji to use and try and find new
ones because i always end up
reverting to the ones i always use yeah
you just kind of like get tired of it
just use the same like four or five
we'll talk about emotions later on and
have you seen there's a lot of stuff on
social media and it says your six most
used ones that is how
you are doing through the pandemic so
that's a fun activity if you want to
look through those
all right the little self personality
trait uh
work on yourself a little little check
on yourself through the emojis cherry
i find that the one that's like this
yeah
works for everything i'm melting
my brain is melting please somebody save
me
from all this working at home stuff all
kinds of the kids are driving me crazy
all of that we're having what for
breakfast let's try it
we're not having breakfast what